you're saying you're a college kid and
you had expectations of yourself that
grand do you remember kind of what you
were thinking back then i mean i just
feel like when you're young you have
kind of unbounded ambition i mean you
don't know the realities of you know
when you build stuff and you face
challenges and you face hiccups and
everything from team to technology to
markets you're naive in the sense that
like the whole world can and should be
different and you know that blind
optimism is where a lot of energy comes
from that i think drives great
entrepreneurial success stories my
orientation was never about starting a
bunch of companies or making a bunch of
money it was much more about kind of
impact and solving big problems and
having great breakthroughs and seeing
those breakthroughs really change the
world